hundreds of migrants stuck at the border
between belarus and poland are to spend
another cold night without shelter amid
a bitter standoff between the two sides
belarus says it will not stop migrants
trying to cross its borders into eu
territory but eu member poland is
refusing to let the migrants in and has
warned of an armed escalation if the
situation continues
people caught in the middle as tension
builds between poland and belarus
on the belarus side of the border
hundreds of migrants are camped out in
the freezing cold watched over by polish
police and soldiers across the barbed
wire
poland's prime minister matteo
schmoyowski visited troops massed along
the border he said belarus was using the
migrants as quote live shields in a new
kind of hybrid warfare
poland has closed an official border
crossing from belarus
in a tweet moroviatsky said today the
stability and security of the entire eu
is at stake this hybrid attack of
lukashenko's regime is aimed at all of
us we will not be intimidated and we
will defend peace in europe with our
partners from nato and the eu
the eu accuses belarus of flying
migrants into minsk then helping them
get to the borders with its eu
neighbours in an effort to destabilize
the block
belarus denies this blaming poland for
escalating the crisis and using
excessive force to push back migrants
belarusian leader alexander lukashenko
says he does not want an armed
confrontation but nor will he back down
we know our place but we will not kneel
poland has declared a state of emergency
along the border
journalists and humanitarian groups are
barred from the area
on the other side only belarus
state-aligned media has access
the migrants have mainly come from the
middle east many fleeing war or poverty
they want to head further west for a
better future in europe
human rights activists say food and
medicine are in short supply and
temperatures are dipping below freezing
a humanitarian crisis unfolding as the
threat of conflict rises
well dw correspondent marina strauss is
reporting from just outside poland's
border exclusion zone from which
independent journalists are banned
here it seems very quiet but of course
we don't really know what's going on
inside the exclusion zone and what's
going on at the border because we cannot
uh verify what's happening and there is
a belarusian journalist an independent
one who is tweeting relatively often who
has been tweeting during the day and he
says that it's relatively calm at the
border and we've seen the pictures of
the tens of thousands of migrants
camping at the border we also know that
there are migrants in the woods here at
the polish side
it's freezing cold
i'm wearing the three kinds of jackets i
imagine that it must be really hard to
to stick out here during the night right
now
give us a sense of the mood there marina
uh polish people are a bit um
like
split some say yes we of course we have
to protect the polish border which is
also the eu's external border so we
cannot let everyone in here um and we
cannot also bow to the pressure of
the of the lukashenko of belarus who
sends the migrants here to our country
but there are also of course a lot of
polish people who
say we have to do something about this
we cannot leave the people like women
children young people in the cold and
just not not act and here in the region
there are also many people who help
migrants and refugees
all right thank you for that marina
strauss near the border between poland
and belarus
well dw correspondent terry schultz in
brussels says poland's president has
been speaking with nato about this tense
situation
this is is not a situation that nato
would would physically get involved in
uh the secretary general sends out
regular messages of support for poland
latvia and lithuania all of which are
our nato members um but just today the
polish president called nato chief
stoltenberg to um basically give him an
update on the situation on the
escalation and to warn him that you know
be ready because if this doesn't um if
this doesn't simmer down then this could
be a problem for you for nato and poland
is asking some specific things of nato
in addition to expecting the same of the
european union and that is that nato
uses its contacts in the middle east in
some of these governments in iraq in
qatar um in the uae to say the same
thing that the european union is going
to say and that is stop the flights
because poland very much sees the
flights as the problem if you stop these
people from getting on a plane you stop
the possibility that they get to the eu
border and you take that that uh
tool out of the hands of the lukashenko
regime so nato is being asked to use its
diplomatic contacts in the same way that
the european union is so very much um
wanting soft power used so that it will
never come to to hard power there is a
final possibility for for poland and
that is that it can call what are called
article 4 consultations and that is if
this gets so bad that poland feels this
is a threat to its national security but
a polish diplomat tells me they're not
anywhere near that quite yet